[Music]
let's go to new york city new york mike
is there mike how can we help
hey guys thanks for taking my call i
love the show thank you sir how can we
help you
uh so i graduated school in 2020 with
about 47 000 in student loan debt
and uh over the past 18 months i've been
paying that down even though it's been
in forbearance
with everything going on in the news
recently and talks with biden writing
off 10k
of student loans it just so happens that
i'm at about 10 000 left
so i'm just kind of
wondering should i
just keep paying it down or
potentially leave free money from the
government on the table
i'm sorry i'm not laughing at you i'm
laughing at that statement free money
from the government uh a thing that
doesn't exist actually it's always
coming back to you one way or the other
and um
i could be wrong on this and i'm hoping
i'm wrong
um
but
i don't see it happening i think it's a
campaign year midterm elections are
coming up and i think this is something
that uh gets dangled out there
because it is uh
it's a winning talking point in that a
lot of people have student loans are
going oh that would be great it'd be
great it'd be great um but i just do not
expect it to happen because quite
frankly student loans are big money
business for the government george yeah
i'm i'm 100 with you ken as i was
laughing at the uh the idea of well in
the news there's been talks
oh a politician talking look at that
that's progress
and so i'm not banking on that and like
ken's saying what's happening here is
approval ratings are low midterms are
coming up we got to make him look good
to get rea so what's happening here is
they dangle the carrot to make people
vote and then they keep kicking the can
down the road and as we've seen the
student loan forgiveness stats are
abysmal
one or two percent of the people that
applied have been forgiven and you've
already done the hard work mike to get
down to ten thousand dollars from 47. so
how many more months is it going to take
for you to pay off
i should be done in in august
i'll tell you this much by august there
will not it will not have happened
i'm happy to be wrong like ken said and
uh you will not look back with regret
when you're debt-free and you don't have
a payment in the world you know just be
happy for those that got their 10 000
paid off if it even ever happens but i'm
not holding my breath
and mike listen you're a good dude i
mean you're a high character guy that's
why you've already gone after it you
know you've already been paying it down
even though they were in forbearance and
uh smart listen
you took out the loan does not make you
evil does not make you bad you're not a
criminal you're not a person of low
character but you signed up for that you
took it out and paint it back and i just
think that you know we've got to
remember this folks that you know you
know
the end of the day i understand why
emotionally if you've been under the
weight of these loans that you're
holding out for it but i wouldn't hold
out for it yeah well people feel like
they've been lied to when it comes to
the entire student loan crisis and
college and the promises at the end of
the day at what point do we go well we
should extend this to credit card debt
and all kinds of debt and the truth is
you signed up for the debt you got to
pay it back that's just how it works you
don't want to do that don't go into debt
yeah
so uh way to go mike keep paying it off
call us back when you're debt-free we
would love to celebrate with you august
is going to be here before you know it
mike really proud of you man keep on
going and it's it's it's gonna be a
challenge that you look at on the other
side of this thing of being free of that
student loan debt you're gonna look back
and it's gonna it's gonna really build
character it's gonna teach you a lot
it's it's going to remind you later on
in life where you have another challenge
that you can do it so
there's nothing but positives by paying
this off